بعد عام من احتلال القدس كامله بشقيها
الشرقي والغربي قررت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تثبيت التاريخ يوما لتوحيد القدس في العام
نفسه جمع الحاخام المتطرف
اتبعه ورفعوا العلم الاسرائيلي في محيط
باب العمود بعد السته اعوام نظمت الميدو
كوك الحاخام المتطرف يهدى حزاني مسيره
لرفع العلم الاسرائيلي يعتبر حازاني احد
قاده الصهيونيه الدينيه انتجت الصهيونيه
الدينيه في اخر تجلياتها لتمر بنجفير اصبح
بنجبير وزيرا في حكومه توصف بالاكثر تطرفا
في تاريخ اسرائيل الى جانب وزراء اخرين
ابرزهم سكوتريتش الذي دعا سابقا الى محو
قريه حوار الفلسطينيه هنا ينفس موتريتش
وجود شعب فلسطيني اصلا تصريحات اثارت
سابقا غضبا واسعا وكشفت وجها اخر للحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده يشارك هذان الوزيران
الى جانب مسؤولين ووزراء اخرين في مسيره
الاعلام هذا العام
تجبر سلطات الاحتلال الفلسطينيين من اصحاب
المحال في البلده القديمه بالقدس على
اغلاقها يوم المسيره تنطلق المسيره من
الشق الغربي للمدينه الى باب العامود
تحديدا ويدخل بعض المستوطنين من باب
الخليفه نقطه النهايه هي الحائط الغربي
للمسجد الاقصى حائط البراق هنا يتجمع
المستوطنون ويرقصون باعلامهم قبل عامين
منعت الحكومه الاسرائيليه مرور المسيره
عبر باب العمود وحولت المسار الى باب
الخليل لتفادي مرورها بالحي الاسلامي مع
تجمع المستوطنين في باب العمود حينها
اطلقت المقاومه الفلسطينيه دفعه من
الصواريخ باتجاه القدس فتفرقت المسيره
واندلعت معركه سيف القدس وفق التقديرات
وقد كلفت المسيره عام 2018 قرابه
الثلاثمائه الف دولار امريكي
تلك مسيره بدات متواضعه عام 74 يسخر منها
التيار العلماني في اسرائيل ووصلت اليوم
لتصبح علامه استفزاز استيطاني تشارك فيها
وتدعمها الحكومه الاسرائيليه